hello everyone and welcome back to the
second game of the second match of the
legends of chess tournament between
yanni pognish and magnus carlson after
magnus
won in round one and nepo now has the
chance with the white pieces to
retaliate in game two so let's see if he
will be able to do it
at the force uh uh well uh things to go
in his favor
and maybe even win this match to force a
third match
so uh let's see what happens nepo again
like in day one opens with e4
and magnus like in day one replies with
c5 so will we see a repetition of the
knight or from day one and the nipples
uh
nicely prepare rook to g1 line uh well
let's
see what happened knight f3 we have d6
and d4 so everything the same like in
day one captures captures and the knight
to f6 we have knight c3
and again a6 magnus does go for the
knight of sicilian but we don't see rook
to g1 here instead nipple goes for the
atoms attack with h3
and okay with e5 by magnus the most
popular reply to the atoms
and here not knight to e2 which is
usually played
knight to b3 by nippo uh also usually
played the knights the e2 is just much
more common so
bishop b7 and now uh the immediate the
g4 so going for the g5 move
h6 preventing this and bishop to e3 nepo
just continues development we have
knight beat to d7 and
now a4 uh and here uh there is a game
where this position has been reached
where magnus had the white pieces he had
he had it uh last year in defeated grand
swiss
against surya shekar ganguly where
ganguly played b6 and magnus was able to
win that game however here uh
by playing the black pieces magnus goes
knight to f8
and it's not a new move it has been
played before the the ideas shift the
knight over to g6 as
the f4 and h4 square has been weakened
by the push of the g4 pawn
uh so uh here uh we have uh bishop to c4
and the queen to d2 is a known move in
this position however bishop to c for
the move nipple place
is a new move so already as of movie 11
we have a completely new game
uh magnus continues with his development
knight g6 prepares the castle king side
and
queen to e2 now uh nepo with with the
idea of maybe castling queen side with
bishop to d7 by magnus and now f3
strengthening the pawns here but kind of
weakening the dark squares we have
rooked the c8 putting pressure on the
bishop
the queen does defend it for the moment
but now now instead of castling queen
side nipple goes for the immediate
h4 he says now my king is perfectly safe
on e1 there's no
no reason to to castle here and magnus
says okay let's
let's test this hypothesis uh by going
knight to
knight to h7 and now there's a triple
attack on the
uh h4 pawn and nepo advances at the h5
so this is definitely something nipple
prepared
uh because magnus does go for knight
bishop to h4
check and he says what do you do now so
king to f1 is one possibility but nepal
plays the rook captures on h4 and this
is where the fun really starts because
the problem
is that you cannot capture with the
queen if you could capture with the
queen it'd be great because it does come
with
check but once you block it uh if you go
queen to h1 check
the king can just move and then you
again have to move the queen because it
will be under attack by rook and then
you lose another piece
so here you'd have to go back and then
just h captures on g6 and what you've
done is basically
lost uh uh two pieces for the rook
so this is not possible to be uh
captured by the queen so magnus goes for
the only other moon knight captures an
h4 which seemingly wins the exchange
but the question is how is the knight uh
going to return as
both the g6 and the f5 square are
squares are covered by
uh nipples pawns so it in fact is uh
a knight that will be captured sometime
soon so nepo castles queen side now
uh and here while you could try and do
something
let's say anything uh magnus says okay
we cannot save this knight so might as
well
grab this beautiful f3 pawn which is the
base of the pawn chain here
do some damage as we're going to lose it
anyway so here rook
captures on d6 first uh point is uh if
queen captures then rook captures on c4
but one thing nipple could consider is
bishop captures on f7 giving it up
this way and after queen captures maybe
continue playing it like this and now uh
even though
it's possible to play this with black
maybe in a rapid game it would be
somewhat harder to defend
this position than the one nippo chose
here nepo went for rook captures on d6
instead
but now magnus says okay no problem
queen e7 and now your rook is under
attack so here rogue b6 by nipple
going after the pawn here but now bishop
captures on g4
and now uh well uh instead of uh
doing some damage here or getting rid of
this knife maybe even capturing an f7
now you have this position where it's
not all that clear what you are doing so
here bishop goes to d5 now puts pressure
on b7 wants to go after that seventh
rank but now uh
just castles king side and now magnus
says
you are welcome to go after the the the
b7 pawn because if this
uh if you capture on b7 i don't really
mind my king is nicely
castle i'm going to go to h4 and
everything is perfectly fine here next
my knight is coming back into the game
and so on and so on the rooks are coming
into the game
it's going to be a very very comfortable
position not right away obviously as
you do have this f7 pawn to worry about
but nothing uh
will come out of this captures on b7 so
instead we have queen to g2 by nepo
unpinning and also threatening the pawn
here
and now queen to h4 again and now that
the queen
has come to h4 it's a very it's very
uncertain how you will
do this because okay you couldn't move
the bishop because of bishop captures on
h6 or even rook captures on h6 the g
pawn is pinned due to the queen being on
g2
but now nipple continues attacking like
like a madman or or should we say
well let's not say it i know you guys
know what i'm talking about
rook to g6 and now there's a double
attack on the bishop of course the rule
cannot be captured because the bishop
pins the df pawn however uh we have
knight
h the g5 by magnus now there is there
isn't a double attack here
and uh what what do you do here well
nepo improves the position with king to
b1
but now bishop back to e6 now offers a
trade here
uh and nepo decides that uh well it's
time to it's time to continue the attack
and instead of going bishop captures
nipple goes
rook captures he gives up the other rook
as well
we have f captures and now bishop
captures on b7 as this is defended so
you can capture here so bishop captures
attacks the rook
but now queen to e1 checked by magnus
we have bishop to c1 blocking and now
rook
captures on c3 so uh this is this is
incredible stuff we have b
captures and now knight captures an e4
so what what do you do here uh well your
if
your c3 pawn is under attack so you have
to take care of this knight
so bishop captures and now queen
captures on e4 and now
bishop captures an h6 threatening
checkmate on g7 and magnus defense
and after all is said and done we reach
this end game where it's
queen bishop and knight against queen
rook and knight
with four pawns each and will uh nip
will be able to
uh to hold this will he be able to win
this or will magnus
prevail so let's see what happens we
have bishop back to c1 nepal now uh
might even consider pushing the h pawn
we have queen to f5
uh and now attacking the pawn here but
now queen e2
so here uh going after the a6 pawn we've
rooked the c7
now putting pressure on the c3 pawn and
here nepo defends it king b2
and here magnus goes for queen captures
um
on h5 right away however there was the
interesting idea that karpov suggested
in the live stream of e4 just giving up
the a6 pawn and shifting the queen over
here because
after this is captured in queen e5 the
only way to defend on c3 is to go queen
to a5 but here
carp probably thought that you just
trade
and after rook a7 you're going to win
this pawn as well knight c6 or whatever
rook captures and you trade you've
traded down into a winning end game
so it's uh it's remarkable how carp of
uh it's such an such an age still you
know spots
instantly such uh positional ideas uh
which which is just incredible
uh but okay carlson goes for queen
captures on h5 and now queen captures an
eight on a6 and now it's a bit different
because the queens are still on the
board
and nepal also has a past a pawn now
that he can push so queen to e8
uh controlling the back rank also
defending the e6 pawn and now
queen b5 here nepo now offers a trade he
would very much like
to trade here get this pawn over here
maybe get some two connected pass pawns
uh and so on
so queen c6 magnus says yes we will
trade but i'm not
getting this pawn all the way to b5 so
here's c4 again with the same idea
if you trade you just nipple's pawn
structure but now king f7 magnus starts
bringing the king into the game
we have c5 even now of course if you
trade then it's
just two connected past pawns it's uh
you do not want to play against this
so after c5 we have knight to d4
attacking the queen and
the knight but magnus uh is avoiding the
trade with uh
uh with queen to f1 with check sorry
nepo avoids the trade magnus
welcomes the trade uh we have king the
g8 getting out of the way and now
bishop to e3 and here we have uh some
trades
queen captures an a4 bishop captures on
d4 we have e captures and queen to f4
now
with a double attack on the pawn here
and under rook here so
queen to d7 not giving up pawn for pawn
magnus says okay if i can consolidate
start pushing these pawns then it's just
uh two very nice pawns in the center
so queen e5 by nipple not allowing it a
very nice centralizing move with the
queen but now
rook b7 uh and okay we have queen to e4
uh sorry uh queen
queen to e4 uh just uh putting pressure
on that
rook there uh and also keeping an eye on
this d3 push which could be
could be very interesting but now rook
back to b8 so magnus just needs a move
that
the rook is isn't under attack and then
he can play queen to d5 to offer a queen
trait here
so queen e5 again attacking the rook but
now rook to b4
again defending the pawn and now
preparing queen d5 we have queen e4 and
now
finally queen to d5 but nepo of course
has to avoid the queen trade he goes
queen g4 and now
uh there's a lot of pressure on the
knight on b3 so this spawn push could be
a problem unless
it's not and here it's not because if
you push it you lose the rook so queen
g4
a good square for the queen but now we
have rook to c4 by magnus
uh probably with the idea of pushing the
pawn now but
queen back to f4 and now uh what do you
do here
well you could play d3 but then you have
to calculate a lot of checks with queen
b
queen b here check queen back check
queen c7 check if the king goes to the h
file queen h2 check
so that's a lot of checks to calculate
so instead magnus repeats rook b4 we
have queen g4
another repetition and the queen to f5
now
uh but now nepo goes rooked a queen to
h4 and here
uh well magnus was able to push the
queen away and here
you could play queen captures on c5 as
the knight is pinned but there is also a
move that you could play
which ud pogar spotted in the in the
live chat in the live stream
uh during the coverage uh and this is
just a wonderful idea so
feel free to pause the video and try and
spot you this idea uh well i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
the well the most beautiful move in the
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's queen
captures on c2
crazy stuff but the point is that now
after king captures d3 check wins the
queen on h4 so king captures rook
captures
and now the point is you have two points
and the rook against the pawn and the
knight which is completely winning and
only thing you have to realize
is that after c6 king f7 uh pawn here
the rook
manages to to stop the pawn and now you
have a completely winning end game
so this is one thing you could have done
magnus goes for rook to c4 instead
uh now puts pressure on the c2 pawn and
now we have queen to d8 to check by nepo
king h7 and queen back to h4 with check
king g6 and now
there are no more useful checks so nepo
goes for knight captures on d4 but now
there's a there's a similar idea here
where you can again go queen captures on
c2 with check knight captures and real
captures you go into
an improved version of that end game
because your king is already
on a much more active square however
magnus keeps everything on the board
he pins the knight now there's a double
attack here he doesn't want to
probably over calculate this and both of
them are extremely low on time so he
goes for this
but now queen g for check king h7 and
now queen h for check of course nepo
would be very happy with the draw here
king g8 queen d8 czech king f7 now and
queen to d7 check
king f6 and now as there's still a
double attack here and the pin
c3 defending end on pinning but now rook
captures on c5 so this is what magnus
wanted to achieve
queen to d8 with check and now king g6
we have queen to e8 with czech king to
h7
and now queen back to d8 so now it's uh
it's carlson's move
rook to d5 attacking the queen but now
again queen h4
check we have king to g8 this square is
now off limits so queen to g4
and now with a double attack on the pawn
here rook d6 defending the pawn and now
again
queen h4 uh waiting for uh for magnus to
find a move and it's not all that
easy because uh well this knight does a
wonderful job at
defending all of the squares in front of
the white king so it's not that easy to
check in
so queen f6 offering a trade queen e4 of
course declining the trade
rook b6 check now king to c2 and now
king to f7
again not a lot not a lot of useful
checks we have queen to a8 now
and the queen to g6 check king to d2 and
now
rook to b2 with check magnus finds some
progress here
king to e3 and now queen g1 check
what do you do with the king of course
not king of three because queen h1 check
then uh
loses the queen on a8 so here queen king
to d3 but now
queen f1 check king to e3 and now queen
to f2 check we have king to d3 and here
magnus played queen
to g2 uh offering a queen trade uh
saying that okay uh what do you do now
and
probably the best and most complicated
for nepo is to either
trade queens and try and hold this which
is very unlikely or or continue checking
and then after let's say this this
just to keep the queens on the board
however nepal went for knight to f3 he
blocked it instead
but now there are problems queen e2
check king to d4 and now queen to d1
with check king back to e3 now rook to
e2 with
check king f4 and then now comes queen
to d6 with
check and now the problem is the king
has to come up the board king g4
rook g2 check as it's possible the
knight blocks the g2 square
came to h5 and here magnus just played
g6
and uh well uh it was in this position
on move 76 that ian nippon should resign
the game
and game two also goes to magnus so he
is very close to winning the
the second match and with it uh the
entire match and
with it the entire uh legends of chess
tournament on chess 24.
so here you resign because it's made
whatever you do if you go here then it's
quinta
uh just uh goes uh goes back to g3 well
i don't know why i'm picking up
the pieces of the wrong color in this
video it's like really weird
queen g3 with the check will be
checkmate and of course after g6 check
if you go up the board then it's the
very sneaky rook h2 check you give up
the rook and now just queen of four
check
wherever the king goes uh well not where
wherever he can only go to one square
then just captures or queen to h4 and
this will be checkmate
so very exciting stuff uh g6 nipple
resigns and
magnus one step closer to winning the
entire thing
so uh that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it i would like to thank joseph
bessette
serge peter taylor oates uh paul neetsov
and uh
gershon muchnik for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing
the coverage of the legends of chess
tournament if there will be more
exciting games
probably will uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the world of
chess so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day